I think I think I'm addicted to noise
you're addicted to noise yeah I feel
like um I feel like I always got
something on
I always have like a video playing I
always have a pot I'm not even listening
it just has to be playing
I always have like some news thing
that's popping up in the background or
um watching some video game or I'm
playing something or I'm scrolling
somewhere sometimes I'm doing four
things simultaneously I'll have a
podcast playing while I'm reading an
article
in fact I just this is Epiphany and I
don't even know how normal this is but I
feel like I'm just consuming media all
the time like so much of it all the time
every time of the day and
um
I also started having a weird pattern
where
the only time that I write any material
for stand up is as I'm trying to fall
asleep
I lay in bed and like everything is
quiet and then my thoughts I hear my
thoughts all of a sudden I'm like oh
yeah this is what it feels like to think
because there's always some [ __ ] that's
on there's always some [ __ ] on like all
the time well yeah at the beginning of a
new comedy you go to sleep and you think
about some [ __ ] you're like oh [ __ ]
that's funny
I'll write it down tomorrow no no you'll
forget I got notes
don't forget you'll forget yeah
and then and then I stay up an extra
hour because now I'm like Oh my phone
like this writing down notes and writing
down punchlines but it's just like
that's the only time because I have
noise all the time I
yeah and I just noticed it over the last
like two three years it's just been like
consistently done so after a while you
just become numb to noise and
get that yeah I need constant
stimulation I can't fall asleep without
a podcast what's crazy is like everyone
when they're taking a [ __ ] right they
have their phone right you're scrolling
through some stuff but I've gotten to
the point where I'm so addicted that
I'll put on a YouTube video for a piss
Ed 25 second piss I'm like I need to be
entertained you always need to be
simulated I'm like what the [ __ ] is
wrong with me I've never touched it with
Simon's phone cause I know he didn't
watch it before
or after he handled that phone
everything he probably pissing
hands-free just yeah look Mom no hands
yeah yeah
[Music]
there was a time when I used to like
always have the TV on when I was
sleeping
no no it's it's fairly calm and quiet I
need my quality calm and quiet
because I'm not coming here just for
calm and quiet and just work on [ __ ]
it's not the level but I feel like you
always on your phone anyways
not always on my phone
so you know sometimes I'm driving okay
I hope I hope that's an exception
[ __ ] out here just
foreign
that's noise because I see noise not in
the sense that it's actual audible noise
I see noise in the sense that's
something it's just
distraction oh but sometimes it's like
you know you ever look at a TV screen
when there's like no channels on it's
just like white stuff yeah it's like
that sometimes we just need that but
sometimes I go into
um in the room yeah and I just stay
there because I don't hear the noise
from outside and I don't have no phone
just and I just think think in a dark
room yeah there's no there's no uh
Windows anything it's just just some
dark room so it's kind of the
representation of inside my brain and I
can just
float and see things in my mind but yeah
no sometimes I need my peace and quiet
but I understand that we like we're more
stimulated by a lot of things like
we're over stimulated
in terms there's always we can have
access to a lot of things to we're bored
we're on our phone
awkward situation phone
tuition or let me just oh let me that
thing I was talking to you about phone
so yeah we we have that that that thing
where we were always simulated we always
have access to it you know I mean
because the thing you become so
constantly stimulated that after a while
you're just not stimulate at all because
you get so saturated with so much your
nerves are just like shot constantly
feeling right
so it's just like why am I even doing it
doesn't even feel good or doesn't you
feel entertaining interesting
I know I hate it I understand it I just
Chuck my phone across the room and like
don't even come near me stupid
all right I have to do that to myself to
consciously do that suck your phone and
say get off me stupid yeah it's awesome
like that I talk to myself
it's really to myself yeah that's what
you're saying yeah
my phone could talk back yeah my phone
would hate the [ __ ] out of me
my phone would hate to shut the amount
of times I chucked that [ __ ] yeah you
took that [ __ ] yeah but there's a lot
of talkable [ __ ]
chuckable worthy [ __ ] on internet that
you watch me like Ugh yeah yeah
so that's been something I've been
dealing with all week There's a trend on
YouTube on Facebook right now is that
their videos and there is no purpose in
that video oh yeah
then you're waiting
to see what the end of the video is to
see what the [ __ ] is this guy doing at
the end of the video the guy is doing
nothing like a complete waste of time
it's so absurd like this without seeing
the video it's hard to know what that's
like okay so what it is while the last
video I saw like that I was pissed off
after watching it it's a guy he's uh
there's a toilet bowl and he has a a
drill and he's poking four holes six
holes in that the cover of the toilet
and he's putting a tube in those holes
and he pours a Gatorade in the tube
foreign
the the trolling me appreciates it like
no
no pistol you're there watching this
[ __ ] like what's he gonna do but you
know what that that is some of the best
performance art in a way because as you
are browsing this app for no [ __ ]
purpose yeah here's some content that's
going to remind you of how [ __ ] boys
and it's actually impactful yeah I saw
that as I was browsing I'd be like I
need to delete this yeah no but you're
you're like you're right because I was
watching that and I said
all right I gotta get on with my day
yo what the [ __ ] am I doing right now I
gotta get up how did you even find that
video that means that so many people
watched it and were disturbed by what
they saw it reflected something in the
emotions let me see if I can find it
because we go to Facebook for a payoff
and here's a video or a Content piece of
content that tells you like there is no
payoff
no there's no reward there's none
there's none why are you here and I
don't know to me there's just some
poetic about me no I don't find the
video there's something really but it
was yeah it was just oh my God
what a [ __ ] heat waste all right I
gotta get on with my day yeah I got out
of bed and I went to take a shower it
motivated me so I guess there's a
purpose for that but it just to remind
you that
you ain't doing [ __ ] right now and
there's something better that you should
be doing those minutes you're never
gonna get yeah never gonna get Never
Gonna Get It Never Gonna Get never gonna
get it nah they're gonna get Never Gonna
Get It Never Gonna Get It
[Music]
you uh you have any long-term goals I
want to make money that's it I want to
make money but money's a tool what do
you want to make money for I want to
make money in dope [ __ ]
right
long-term goals people always ask me
that and I always say like I have no
idea
listen the
I want to do what I do right now really
good yeah so I could chill later
right I want to be able to chill but
what's going to permit me to chill I
want to do dope [ __ ] with it I want to
be able to have fun Okay so
yeah
long-term goals such a vague question
things can change I don't know how I'm
going to feel in five minutes
so it's hard for me to be like okay in
10 years okay I could never answer oh
how where do you see yourself in 10
years I agree is there a moment you'd
like to achieve some people have like a
flash point of something they would like
to do or it's like
maybe for you it's just for laughs you
know maybe for somebody else it's going
on tour for someone else sitting on the
countryside with their family by a house
that they bought is there a moment for
you that you see in your head that's
already passed yeah what was that moment
me doing what I love and getting paid
for it okay the rest is really gravy
like I told you that numerous times
I just wanted to pay my bills
that's if if I can manage to pay my
bills
and not kill myself because I'm so
miserable with my job or everything
around me
yeah if I can just not be miserable and
be good with what I do that's what I
want to do yeah and it's it's it's it's
kind of the motivate the motivation that
that
like whenever I go on YouTube and I see
like comments and [ __ ] and I'm like
oh you hate me and you don't like what I
do or you say all this [ __ ] about me
I'm still good
I don't know about you
person talking [ __ ] or maybe they're not
talking [ __ ] maybe like the person that
likes me the person that hates me those
two people they're both right okay
so I don't really care like that like
like it affects you sometimes like okay
that was that that's tongue a bit but
whatever you know I mean at the end of
the day I'm looking back on what I do
and what I'm doing I'm like ugh I'm good
I'm good
so I guess
that moment already passed the rest is
really gravy
I got our aspirations to do other [ __ ]
other dope [ __ ] of course but
I just wanted to pay my bills and not be
miserable
man I just want that moment to the last
as long as I can that's the goal it's
not going through the mountain and
staying on top
right
so
yeah man
yeah life right for me kind of feels
like
feels like um
you ever you know that Roadrunner
cartoon where the road runners is
running and then he runs off a cliff but
he keeps going
um it doesn't stop there's like nothing
that's what life feels like well because
there's a rule in cartoons
you don't fall if you don't look down
exactly
that's what life feels like sometimes
because I'm like
sometimes I ask myself how I got to
where I am and it feels like I never
stopped
you just keep moving because you know
when you run down a hill you got so much
momentum you use snowballs
and you don't even know like where you
were trying to go when you ran down the
hill you just kept going and like the
speed kind of carried you there
I feel like that a lot of times in life
when people like sometimes ask me like
what's that goes like I never really
thought about it I just kept moving but
I think that's one of the things that
you told me the most what
all right whatever keep it moving you
said that I don't know how many times
you said that whenever there was
something that was happening to us or
something good something bad something
in in the bad stuff I can understand eh
whatever there's nothing we could do
about that keep it moving it's great for
the good stuff whenever the good stuff
happened we had some good moments and
you're like all right good keep it
moving
yeah well I mean
come from where I came from and having
to live on my own since I was a teenager
it's like
you'll have to do that in order to stay
afloat that's what our parents had to do
when they came here exactly so you just
you keep it pushing
now I don't need to
but you still do it but I'm still moving
well that's just and I'm because and now
that I got more time to think I'm like
what if I look down right now you get
what I'm saying yeah
and that's just like the realization
I've been having for quite some time
where it's like
what is
what is the reason I'm still allowing
the momentum to push me forward
before I was like I needed to get away
from where I was
now I don't need to get away from there
why am I still allowing this to take me
wherever it's going and do I even want
to go where it's going because I don't
want to look down
yeah I don't I don't want to look down
yeah because I mean we soaring right now
we're flying that's why that's why the
compliments will feel weird to me
because I'm not looking I feel like
looking down is like just dwelling in
everything that's happening sometimes I
look back about the achievement that I
that I did and stuff like that but I
don't stand it too much I'm comfortable
I'm not sure keep me moving let's go
just keep on going I gotta the monkey
it's always the biggest conversation
that I have on my girl because she's
like yeah but aren't you proud that's
not what I said
yeah but like you have to be able to you
have to be proud of yourself that's not
what I said I just said that one it
feels weird and two I gotta keep on
going I got other [ __ ] to do I got other
[ __ ] to achieve all right I got other
ideas I want to do other stupid [ __ ] if
you understand what I'm saying but yeah
I understand the feeling when you don't
want to look down you don't want to look
you don't want to look at
you don't want to dwell into that and
bask and I feel like
all those people with potential and you
never heard about after that that's a
bit of what happened when something gets
to their head
one like famed yesterday had or whatever
gets to their head they're like yeah I
did that and everything and stuff that's
them looking down I don't want to be
that guy I don't want to be that dude I
just want to keep on keep on going
there's other things mental health
whatever issues and this and that but
sometimes there's that looking down yeah
I don't think I'm worried about
congratulation or things like that I
think it's more so the why
I think
if I imagine that the Roadrunner analogy
the running is the actions we take every
day
and the little work that we do that's
propelling us and moving us forward then
what's beneath is really the foundation
what's like sustaining you through that
and the speed is what's keeping me
flying after I've gone off the cliff
but then
what's beneath is like you realize like
there's nothing underneath it and and
that's not really bad thing or maybe you
just want to keep flying and soaring
that's great but it's like at some point
you don't want to fly all the time
what's the purpose of a roadrunner
his name is Roadrunner
there's runner in what he does so if
your purpose is that
then that's why you keep on going
because you could do it and it's okay to
do it and that's your purpose that's
what you do okay you find something you
found something it's not deceived it
doesn't mean that you're you think it's
gonna your your mindset or your purpose
is Gonna Change it's not going to change
it might change but for now that's your
purpose so Roadrunner is going to do
what a roadrunner does and it's gonna
run and keep on going if that's what's
your purpose and that's what you're
supposed to do You're Gonna Keep on
doing just that because that's what
you're supposed to do it's comfortable
doing it are you forcing yourself
whenever you're going down that hill or
running off the cliff as if are you
forcing yourself
um I don't think I'm forcing myself I
don't even it feels like um it's just
momentum it's no effort so maybe just
use the momentum yeah but it's not about
effort I'm talking about effort I'm
talking about
it almost feels like it's a different
energy that's propelling me there so
it's not a conscious Choice sometimes
it's like um it's more so the force of
past choices made propelling me down for
example it's like somebody going to
school and they've invested a bunch of
money into the education and they've
paid a bunch of student loans and
they're three years in it's like
sometimes what's repelling you forward
isn't like purpose it's like [ __ ] I've
already put in so much you get what I'm
saying so momentum is a wonderful thing
because as you accumulate more of it you
Snowball right you the the running
becomes effortless because you've
already built so many good habits you
already got so much momentum and power
pushing you forward you're gonna catch
up so much speed so it's great
but it also means you lack a bit of
control
it's harder to control yourself when
there's so much momentum much right when
you're running down a hill at full speed
like one trip and you're gonna [ __ ] up
your face right
um
and so I think
when it comes to Life's decisions I
think that often feels that way I'm not
even saying it's necessarily a bad thing
because sometimes momentum care you
somewhere amazing
um
I think it's just when you don't have
that control sometimes it could be
it could be strange it could be
strangers knowing like
all right I'm here because I'm like so
much push
and how much of it
however how much of it do you want and
how much of it is a good and like when
do you ever get to stop and like think
about all right why
other than that I know I know how I got
here I'm not sure why
I think that's more sort of a
philosophical question um
that's a lot of [ __ ] question
I just want to do dope [ __ ] yeah yeah
and I mean listen I thought that way for
a long time yeah I can understand that
what's gonna happen is that you have to
just know if are you tired or not
are you tireing yourself is the momentum
bigger than your capacities
you understand what I'm saying sometimes
you're going down the cliff and then
you're rolling you're rolling you got
momentum it's that time some point it's
easy but then the momentum is faster
than you like are you tired are you are
your legs flinching is that what it is
that's what you can control yeah here's
the wonderful thing about that is that
you don't necessarily have a boss over
you the boss is you the boss is who you
feel that you are in charge of right and
providing for them they're not your boss
but you decided that they they were
the burden you know I mean so then after
that you have to decide what you're
willing to do for that it's either you
set [ __ ] up so that whenever you can
take a break you can take a break so
that whenever the momentum is become
starting to be too [ __ ] up you can tap
the brakes whatever the [ __ ] you want um
or you're really in line with what you
you do and
yeah you slow down the momentum right
now so that the momentum doesn't get too
too [ __ ] up taking my circumstances
out of it I um think about this in terms
of the lives of other people by the way
I think I think about it in the terms of
lives in terms of the lives of other
people yeah and
sometimes you just see people at jobs
who've been there for 25 years
it's like that's just momentum
you know 10 years 15 years past they've
accumulated a few and there's a
difference between momentum and routine
but keep on going I'm sorry I don't want
to cut you well routine is built from
momentum the more you build a habit
you build up that momentum in regards to
um whatever's going on with your life so
the routine comes from you sticking with
whatever it is right momentum is like
basically so what is it it's like force
over time
and then there's like an acceleration
process that happens over there right
it's kind of similar to what happens
with like routines you'll have to do
some repetition all that stuff and the
reason why you settle in is because like
all the forces
that encourage you to settle in keep you
there so you stay at your job for 25
years you're used to that salary people
count on you you got the same people
there
etc etc right you are used to this do I
have to stop and to change all of a
sudden pivot is very very difficult
right not just because of routine but
also because of
I was like when we're talking about like
just life's journey right we're talking
about
what you know
stopping and then having to restart is
super difficult
because you're starting from zero speed
that's hard
that's very difficult and so for most
folks when they've built up that speed
and they've built up that pace and
they're used to it having to stop like
it's like [ __ ] I'm tired I gotta start
this [ __ ] up again so when I think about
other people and they've you know been
at whatever jobs and they hate it and
you know there's a certain sense of
safety that they feel and whatever it is
that they got I'm like damn
whatever
Pace that they've kept
it's like it's hard for them to stop and
to change trajectory
that's been true for like people in my
family in a lot of ways or people around
me
and I wonder sometimes if if those
people ever ask themselves like why
why they are are where they are why
don't they do they question why they are
where they are even though like they're
miserable or they're unhappy or they are
happy do they question the why or is it
just like
the momentum of like my past choices
carry me here and I never stopped I
don't think the older people ask
themselves that question older
immigrants first generation immigrants
oftentimes don't
oftentimes the generation of our parents
they don't ask themselves that they just
got to do what they gotta do that they
got to keep on pushing they ain't got
time to [ __ ] ask am I in line wait
whatever no that's our privilege yeah
they actually move from their countries
to come here
for us to have that privilege of asking
them okay
they oftentimes don't do that they don't
ask themselves those questions right am
I in line with whatever
I gotta do this this is the convenient
thing maybe not but it's working you
know I mean
after that the younger generation I
think we're the one that really
ask those questions you know sometimes I
feel like with all these young folks
they don't even get moving they just
stop and stick the whole time it's like
sometimes [ __ ] you got to move your
legs to figure out how this voice works
yeah you you can't just sit there and
Ponder all day because ain't nothing
yeah just stop and be like I'm lost no
you got to keep on moving and be like
I'm lost but yo let me find the clues or
whatever went on yeah yeah yeah it's
like once you settle into a career it's
hard to just stop that and then choose
something else definitely because you
have all the time you've invested in all
the years you put in obligations all the
connections you have it's like I'm gonna
go back to Step Zero it's like no [ __ ]
I've been running this whole thing for a
while I'm not like the Finish Line gotta
be somewhere you want to be starting you
race [ __ ] I'm still tired
right I haven't completed one lap you
want me to start a brand new one what
the [ __ ] yeah yeah I think I I wonder
because sometimes I hear other people
talk about the whys like we'll be at
their family their kids their dream or
whatever it is and I feel like I've
never really had that I've just had the
desire to get away from what I had look
I I didn't I didn't like where I was so
I needed to go somewhere you get what
I'm saying that's all it's ever been
that's all it's ever been I don't like
where I was I'm going elsewhere
right so that's a simple feeling
now I'm good with where I am so I'm like
why am I still moving
you get what I'm saying yeah and so when
I look at other people I wonder if they
have like a more intrinsic why that
helps them kind of make sense of the
world around them in like the direction
that they're going
and like how real is that I don't know
if people are just like postulating this
[ __ ] or or what but yeah I guess I
was running through my head
oh well
that was a good run from the coyote gee
and everyone's coyote is something
different you know I think people who
get trapped in a routine
there's many different reasons but
there's like the societal kind of idea
that you have to have this stable job
with benefits you know so the coyote for
them I guess is just like
being a loser without those things
without the house you know without the
car without the wife or the husband or
whatever
I feel like we we set these standards
you know it's like you got to be married
by a certain age you got to have this by
certain age so people
yeah I'm going to work for a bank and
hate it and just keep doing it and the
momentum builds and the company knows
that there's that momentum right that's
why they build like a corporate
atmosphere where
they kind of encourage they have these
Sanka sets it's almost like they want
you to date someone within the company
and then it's like oh they got a company
baby now it's like you can't leave the
momentum's there now they're invested
yeah that's my coyote yeah I don't want
that that's what I'm running from yeah
you know that's why I decided to to go
the path I I went so so here's another
question then
and I think what's true for you is
probably true for me as well you think
it's a good thing that we're motivated
by our fears
yeah
I don't I don't see the other wave
I don't I have a hard time seeing other
ways and being motivated by by your
fears you you know hold on you can be
motivated by other things but being
motivated by your fears is normal and I
think it can be healthy the one where it
doesn't when it doesn't become healthy
and it's when there's an obsession then
it becomes a problem when you're not
able to control that and you're stuck in
a pattern where you're always constantly
worrying about that and it's causing you
anxiety and it's causing you to not
being able to function that's another
thing where in another we're in another
realm but if you're you're your goals
are fueled by your fears and it's it can
it can be healthy yeah if it's dope if
it's balanced absolutely it can
definitely be healthy it becomes a
problem when it's out of control I don't
disagree it just sounds weird it does
right so like if someone's to say
I'm doing this because I never want to
go back to being poor
I can understand
something about that sounds [ __ ] up
don't because you don't want to suffer
if if the equivalent of saying is
equivalent of saying I don't want to go
back into suffering I agree but but
here's my thing
what's beyond that what's beyond what
once you reach that point okay you're
not going back what are you living for
after
just stabilizing that when it becomes
when it becomes a problem is when you're
only and constantly thinking about that
and you are
um you're not letting yourself live
because you don't want to be poor you're
become a hoarder of things you know I
mean you you and so so when it becomes
to that extreme where you're extra cheap
you don't want to know if we don't do
this we don't do that and you're you're
[ __ ] up your comfort and your comfort
of other people then it becomes a
problem because you're not even letting
you know yourself so I think I think
what you're missing is this I understand
how it gets you out of that situation
I'm saying how does it sustain you
afterwards so for example here's a
hypothetical take an NBA player wants to
get out of poverty wants to make it to
the league once you get your money what
sustains you in that League it cannot be
your fear of not wanting to go back
those players nevertheless the ones who
stick around are the ones who love the
game
they have a deep sense of appreciation
for the game they just want to be
champions
there's a different motivation there
there's a motivation that I never want
to go back to Poverty which will get you
out of it okay we get it once you're out
of it though what sustains you what's
life after that it's like
when you're in a bad environment
cool you get out of the environment you
know how to get out of it you've done
what you need together doesn't mean you
know how to live now
you know what I'm saying what comes
after that yeah I understand that but
it's it's more
complex than that it's not just you know
the person that does the NBA and like
he's in the NBA now and he he doesn't
want to go back to being poor it's more
than that that person found an Avenue
that he was good at and he'd actually
genuine genuinely loved
you're making the assumption that that's
what I'm saying your assumption we're
making oh this whole thing is assumption
so I'm not saying that it's absolutely
that but I'm saying that it can be that
I'm not saying that automatically hits
that but okay but why not talk about
that I'm talking about folks who want to
escape something so they use something
to get out of them that's that's the
whole thing
I don't want to be poor so I joined the
military we can assume that the person
loves the military but there's I can
tell you for firsthand a lot of the
[ __ ] don't give a [ __ ] they
just want to get away from their
environments which it works what comes
after well I mean those people are more
at risk of a lot of things right they're
more risk of injuries the more risk of
mental injuries and more risk of a lot
of things so what comes after that
it depends of life you're not
necessarily going to be injured you're
not necessarily going to be like PTSD or
whatever whatnot you're not necessarily
going to be in depression but you have
to understand that you have more chances
of that happening to you definitely yeah
if it's not something that you love Yeah
well isn't that most people I feel like
people who go to school they don't love
their [ __ ] major there you know what
they want to do no they just want to
escape whatever uncertainty they were
ever I just want to please people or
they just yeah but again it's the fear
that's motivating them most folks I know
who went to school just didn't know what
they wanted to do they were afraid of
whatever uncertainty so they just pick
something yeah okay so they get you out
of that it gives you an accomplishment
and great it gets you outside of that
bubble you get whatever you need it
doesn't mean that you have what it takes
to sustain you after so that's my
question
you know what I'm saying I don't feel
like most people love what they do I
don't think that people who are
operating off of fear are now choosing
things afterwards out of love no they're
choosing it to get away from what they
are afraid of and so that I don't know
how that sustains you afterwards I guess
that's why well it doesn't
and that in that case if you're talking
about in that case but is it no it
doesn't it doesn't that's why you have
so much oppression that's why you have
so much people that are incompetent at
their job they don't want to be there
they just gotta right you understand and
I think it's generational because
no it's not generational is that we
didn't talk about that my parents didn't
talk about depression or mental health
and stuff like that so I'm not saying
that it did not affect them it did but
they hit that [ __ ] pretty well and now
that being said that being said uh
uh yeah it's not no it's not
you can't live like that really you
can't you just can't you
yeah a bunch of people watching right
now who living like that yeah definitely
what well bro but I was yeah I was
before this comedy [ __ ] and before all
of this stuff I was definitely I was not
in line with me you understand what I'm
saying yeah
definitely a hundred percent so
after that you have to find your way
it's not everybody's gonna find what
they want and then get out of there it's
it's rough but most people yeah in that
sense that's why you have so much
depression
there's a there's a Bill Hicks rant
for sure on YouTube where he talks about
this like
being motivated by fear versus love it's
like super viral from it's probably from
the 80s or something but I think we're
always trying to to find a balance
between those two I think in his rant
he's talking about we have to be
motivated purely by love and not by fear
but I don't know if that's possible I
feel like it's like the yin and the Yang
you're kind of like
trying to find a balance between the two
and ironically when you kind of seek
things you fear you can find something
you love through that in a way I think
it's an Utopia
it's like a dream it's like
the ideal but I don't think that's
really how things work
right because I don't think that's how
any of this works yeah yeah the idea
would be like I'm only motivated by love
it's only love that's cool that's not
how the brain works I don't believe that
the the
that that's how the brain works you know
the Factor Fear The Fear Factor is there
they can be there
and love isn't some like Eternal
tangible thing necessarily like we're
all Comics right we I assume we all love
doing comedy to a certain extent yeah
but like you know I went the route of
pursuing that and overall yes I love
comedy but there's times where I [ __ ]
hate it you know there's times where it
feels like work you know you know you've
all had those hell gigs you show up to
like some small town There's sounds off
the crowd is Rowdy and you're not a milk
crate you know I'm like I don't love
this I don't love anything about this
but I'm and I'm kind of scared almost of
how bad it's gonna go but so there's the
fear there you know it's always like
that balance between
the two a little bit but I'm gonna do it
because on some level I want to conquer
this you know what I mean like overall I
love this thing but it's not like maybe
in that I don't hear the fear I do hear
that you don't love every aspect of it
but it doesn't sound like fear to me at
least in the scenario that you get I
think fear speaks to
a circumstance or an event you want to
avoid or or that scares you
um
what you describe is just like anything
in life there's going to be aspects you
love and aspects you don't love as much
whether it be relationship or a child
you know
um so maybe I don't hear the fear in
there so maybe you wanna
help me hear that because on some level
I mean
I
as much as like I've evolved and
whatever and become better as a comic
and and you know discovered more stuff
about it I still fear doing badly less
than before because you realize like on
the grand scheme one show doesn't really
matter and you kind of have to almost
you know do badly to find new material
yeah you know what I don't matter when
you're bombing the moment that you're
bombing you're like yeah that won't that
moment doesn't matter because you know I
usually don't bomb you don't feel you
don't think that
it still sucks it sucks
while you're bombing yeah you're bombing
that's it but you know what you know
like you were saying preach before you
don't want that to be your only
motivation it becomes paralyzing when
you obsess on just that you know maybe
maybe I'm the opposite I have no issues
bombing you know what I I get terrified
of when I do stand up what being corny
nope I don't even care about that
when I do stand up
I um
I get terrified of the idea
but I'm like almost too comfortable but
I stop actually being creative or stop
trying
you know but that's just that's just
that fear's not
um
I feel like that's almost like the
absence of what I love about standard
what I love about stand up is the
spontaneity it's the interaction and the
connection with the audience when I'm
just there and I'm doing old rehashed
material that I know works and I'm
getting like this inorganic relationship
with the with the audience like that's
what I hate even when I'm doing well
with that stuff I'm like it's time to
move on and I haven't done it and I've
and I'm letting my fear motivate me
rather than my love for standing my fear
of failure is what's motivating me right
now rather than my love of seeing it but
I'm doing well
They're laughing and I'm there like I
hate this
all right so definitely a few words it's
just an explanation of what the feeling
that you have
because you're still gonna do your
react thing what you mean while you're
doing it and you're like oh I hate that
you're still doing it it motivates you
in what sense and not doing it later on
you're doing it the fact that you're
doing that rehash set or whatever
you're doing it now it's going to
motivate you of your fear is going to
motivate you of doing what to just keep
doing that
it stagnates you
um
I think you got to be brave
then I mean I think I think loving
something requires you to be brave to
have some courage not to just be
comfortable
requires you to be uncomfortable
actually oh yeah that's what loving
something requires of you be it a person
be it family you know like
yeah and so
I think when you're motivated by that
then yeah I think you're probably on the
right path more than anything I think
I think fear for me is a great motivator
when you are in crisis
like um I think it's absolutely
necessary and it's normal to have
um but I think once you're out of that I
think you need to have different
motivations
because like when you're thinking about
survival yeah fear is reminding you that
there's real eminent danger it's like a
it's a byproduct of human evolution like
almost any Evolution that's absolutely
necessary can't live in a [ __ ]
dangerous area and not have fear like no
fear is like your body basically telling
you like there's danger you become a
potential provided it's good sensible
fear right so you have to have a good
sense of that right you need to have a
good sense of that to be able to move to
the world but after you pass that
threshold after you get out of that
[ __ ] thing it's like all right I
gotta live with something else like
[ __ ] you can't be in a gated community
motivated by your fear like you gotta
you gotta be good like like you gotta
you gotta live on something else at some
point you know what I'm saying you gotta
you made it out right and that's why
like somebody just make it out but they
still in that hot and then that's like
and [ __ ] them up yeah they've never
been able to let go and that's what I'm
saying we're not saying like that when
the fear is too much and it overpowers
you and then you have PTSD and stuff
like that they come in the position it's
like how are you gonna be rich rich not
higher security and walk with a
illegal firearm with you yeah it's like
they're still stuck in that yeah they're
still stuck in that insecurity that fear
uh but and they do that yeah they're
stuck in their ways so saying it goes
with what you were saying it's not
because you reach a certain level they
reach that certain level of not being
broke anymore right but it doesn't mean
that they're able to function and
they're not because they still have
those same mannerism those theme those
same uh things that they were doing the
same train of thoughts as when they were
broke that broke mentality and they walk
up in the spot with an illegal firearm
and any cancer case
yeah
this whole conversation I feel like is a
metaphor for like human civilization and
evolution right because in the beginning
we're like motivated by a crisis of fear
like running from a tiger or whatever
right and then eventually we're able to
settle and have Agriculture and whatever
and then the motivate you know once we
kind of conquered the natural world to a
certain extent the mode of motivations
became different you know
like you have to move beyond that crisis
but I guess crisis is relative too you
know
it's like is it is it just an immediate
fear or
you know even if you're comfortable
even if you feel like you've gotten past
that crisis mode where you're motivated
purely by imminent fear
there's still things that can kind of
push you backwards or go wrong you know
there's still a little bit of yeah you
know of something pulling you away where
you don't want to look down you know or
whatever
yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
just thinking about [ __ ]
as brutal
but you go through that but that that's
good right it's like it means your point
of like
comfortability in life where you can
think about these things exactly you
know you're not motivated by that
imminent like I can't even philosophize
about it I think it like it it reminds
me that I'm alive because I'm able to
observe myself
and then my own thoughts and then
just try to decipher like ways in which
I'm like fallible and then from there
I'm like okay
like I'm not just moving like it's not
just like this flesh body doing and then
and then talking you know it's like
there's a certain reflection that I'm
trying to go through to to be able to be
like all right like you know you need to
you need to look at yourself and so it's
good in that sense it's good in that
sense because sometimes you're just so
busy moving like you don't even really
consider your own existence you just do
you go here you see this person you [ __ ]
you go home like whatever you're just
doing [ __ ] and I mean like you're just
doing anything so it's good to be able
to slow it down and be able to but you
also don't want to get too stuck in
those Waters because this is deep Waters
and then sometimes that ever happened to
you when you was like a kid when I was a
kid I was like
seven
I just had some moments where I realized
that I was alive like I was just like
it's a weird thing you just realize your
own existence yeah like I'm okay I'm a
human be I'm me
yeah
I'm I'm me
I'm an entities you go from just going
about life because they tell you to him
it's just being like wait wait wait wait
wait a minute wait a minute
I'm my own person I'm I exist
yeah which is uh kind of terrifying just
like what does that mean
and so to come back to the start of this
podcast I think that's what noise is
great for because noise
I bought a white noise machine
yeah yeah it was just a bunch of white
ladies talking about margaritas and
asking for the manager over and over
no it's just like
I feel like all this noise
just like makes you forget yeah
I was like I'll be laying in bed
sometimes and be like damn this is
stressful
oh damn shoulders tits I got paid in my
hips and [ __ ] I was like bro let's get
my massage and [ __ ] that's why it's hard
to do think about nothing when you're
just doing this yeah you know you're
just going through it and you realize
like man
you know I I'm not I'm not the biggest
like Jordan Peterson fan per se
uh but someone just talks in regards to
psychology I think are pretty
fascinating and he's like he's like life
is a catastrophe in a lot of ways a
human existence is it was a calamity and
I don't know why but every time he said
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] always hit home with
me because I always felt
like
I was like in a lot of ways incredibly
beautiful
like I was I had I had spent some time
with
um with my niece and
you know the thing about kids is like
they're so present
it makes you present oh yeah it's the
now it's like you right there right now
you're not elsewhere you're not anywhere
else you're there they're so honest okay
they're looking at you and you're
looking at them you're like there and so
it was like really like something
beautiful about that
and then
and then there's like the Calamity of
life where it's like you have the loss
of life and tragedy and the imagining of
other people's deaths around June like
the you're the nebulous of your own mind
and it's just like [ __ ] that's dark you
know this kid just drooling actually
like
present
and it brings you back right so there's
like that Duality to things that I
always find fascinating but uh yeah even
just being alive like you realize like
damn this is a frightening thing
[Music]
it's like I don't know and it's
sometimes I hear other people talk like
this I'm like let me turn this [ __ ] out
yeah I don't want to have that [ __ ] I
don't know think about this [ __ ]
depressing ass [ __ ] but yeah and now
you're talking about it for like over 45
minutes
yes
about what the [ __ ] I'm thinking about
because I'm mad at it
yeah that's what I was you know it's
like um
yeah sometimes it feels like
all-consuming
so sometimes I have to pull myself out
of the water you said something about
you were seven you realize your life
first time I did mushrooms I realized oh
yeah I got transport I had like I felt
like an out-of-body experience and then
it like made me super conscious of my
inner thoughts and inner dialogue and
things like that are just like activated
um
and so now
I become much more aware of how I think
and why I think about things and I think
it's been good it's been good in the
sense that um
it's helped me take in a lot of new
information but you know sometimes we
all know people in the space who like
they're so dogmatic about everything
they have everything figured out I'm
like [ __ ] you haven't had a
conversation with yourself
you got the momentum of your ideas
carrying you forward and you are running
down this hill so fast even though
people are telling you hey there's like
a pit coming up you've been running and
you refuse to stop
right but the good thing about a little
bit of self-awareness is like hey maybe
that information is good let me take a
second and stop and then reassess where
I'm going and so I think that's it helps
me
it helps me undo and stop
when I need to in adjust directions you
know not just let momentum carry me
forever but I'm not having anything
figured out is not uh it's not a result
of you start talking to yourself that's
some point you're gonna have to you
won't figure something out maybe talking
to you like having everything figured
out what no you know what as I get older
abandoned
you just realized like
I mean there's like so much you don't
know
you know like uh 32 now 30 32 today and
32. happy birthday whatever
um
are we just talking about Finance
I'm talking about money [ __ ] I'm like
[ __ ] I don't know anything yeah I know
you told me that that was like you know
hey you gotta do this and you got to do
that yeah and like you didn't know about
a lot of like you know sexual Dynamics
between the men and women like dating
stuff over the course and you've taught
me stuff about marriage and dating and
I'm still learning stuff from people
around me so
you say something you got no [ __ ] like
do you though you don't know you don't
even my mom you know like even seeing
her change and her like Evolution as a
55 year old woman and it's like damn
but I guess she don't know [ __ ] either
she learned and stuff too yeah yeah you
want you to when you don't know that you
don't know you don't know that you don't
know
sounds super stupid but yeah if you
don't know that you don't know
yeah he got a couple lines like that you
don't know that you don't know the
stupid [ __ ] that's a stupid [ __ ] is
less stupid than a stupid [ __ ] that
doesn't know she's a stupid [ __ ] uh
stupid [ __ ] I know she's a stupid
business that's stupid and stupid [ __ ]
I don't know yeah something like that
makes sense if you like think about it
but yeah she got a couple that's a good
tongue twister for the niece
hey little girl let me teach you
something a stupid [ __ ]
that don't know she's stupid [ __ ] is
less of a stupid [ __ ] than a stupid
[ __ ] and don't that knows she's a
stupid [ __ ] you know what that is deep
that's actually science right there it's
science there's uh something called the
dunning-kruger effect yes right which is
like essentially the more you know about
a topic the less confident you are in
having like a very strong position about
it the more you know about some [ __ ] the
more you notice you you don't know
exactly where you guys where are you
guys on the dinner cougar scale when it
comes to standing I don't know [ __ ] I'm
definitely in the middle section all
right 150 yeah I am
150 the middle section I I don't know
[ __ ]
it was so much more confident in my in
my first two years it's crazy I have so
much less confidence in how good I am of
a stand-up now yeah after doing so much
and seeing so many amazing people and
you know the first few I I feel like you
too like we both started about the same
time we were both doing quite well for
people who are like starting so I was
like man I'm this is it I'm [ __ ] I'm
Russell Peters you know like you crushed
one five minute set yeah and at an open
mic and you're like I'm sorry yeah I'm
like I could do this and then only later
on when you you look back and you're
like oh my God my jokes were so hacking
yeah people were laughing I was doing
well but like [ __ ] I was bad and I was
over confident and I
and then I'm sure I'm going to look back
at myself
in fight I hope that I'll look back at
myself in five ten years time and think
the same about where you myself now you
know
so yeah it's almost like you're you're
at the bottom of a valley and you climb
over the mountain and you feel amazing
you look up and there's like Kilimanjaro
right up ahead and it's like extending
past the clouds you can't even see the
summit of that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's what it feels like that's
what it really feels like you know the
only thing that I think helps me out
when it comes to that stuff is I'm okay
I I'm okay with not being great I'm okay
with not knowing and I accept it I you
know there's a topic of God that comes
up all the time for me people always ask
me so what's your religious belief I'm
like oh
you don't have any religious beliefs do
you believe it's Richard I'm like well I
maybe it could be out there maybe it's
not so you don't think about it I'm like
nope
that is for all the Deep talk we've done
today one thing I literally never take a
second to think about is the existence
of God foreign
it never crosses my mind till someone
asks me then I'm like I don't really
care and I move on and I never think
about it again
and
the reason why is because I'm like I
don't know I have no way of confirming
and it doesn't matter
during the day I'm gonna just be out
here I'm gonna try to do right by the
people around me if God does exist then
hopefully he accepts me knowing like I
try to do or she whatever day God you
know whatever pronoun they prefer okay
accepts me I haven't done what I've done
uh I see God got to be gender neutral
right it's got to be
um
so yeah it was like I don't know to me
and I find folks think about it so much
that's what a religion is
that that's what a religion is thinking
about it so much and then after that
there's the people that are not in
religion but still think about whether
it exists or not I'm gonna be honest
with you I think a lot of folks in a
religion don't even think about it I
think they just accept it
because
they're afraid of the unknown
so they don't think about it they accept
that reality because it's so comforting
yeah you know and look listen whether
you believe it or not I don't put it I
think it's perfectly fine and I think
it's absolutely necessary for a lot of
folks I'm not even here to be like I'm
above that no it's cool
I think a lot of folks don't even think
about it they just it's got to be real
and they stop there they don't question
it my experience with folks who are
hyper religious is they do not question
the existence of God
they accept it as a unit lateral effect
yeah you're right about that
they're the beginning of the
dunning-kruger
no because for them it's not a
progression
right it's an ultimate truth but in this
in a sense like they I feel like
they haven't thought deeply past that at
all like that's the further down the the
curve or whatever yeah yeah that's one
thing I've never what about you guys you
think about the they exists
the more I think about it the less I
think is it exists really
and now I talk to God ironically knowing
you don't exist
yeah sure dude that was you all right
and not just a random lightning all
right
what about you I think uh I have a
scientific view of it but a lot of
people who say that are like oh I'm an
atheist because there's no proof yeah
but I don't think that's a very like
scientific way of actually thinking
about it like if you have an experiment
where you're trying to prove something
in science and you can't find a
conclusion then it's inconclusive yeah
it's not one way or the other but think
about it similarly to you I think where
I'm like I do think about it though I
wouldn't say I think about it all the
time but I don't know and I'm fine with
that there's no there's no evidence
yeah
but for me that the fact that there's no
evidence doesn't prove without a doubt
that there is nothing or it doesn't
exist it just it's inconclusive that's
it I like that I like that
even though I don't think about God's
existence ever I do love
thinking about like religious edicts and
I love thinking about them in more
abstract sense and really believing that
they're real so whenever people talk
about like angels and devils
I don't think about them
in literal senses I think about them in
abstract sets and I feel like they're
real
I feel like there's people in the world
that I think you can divide that way or
even the idea of Hell In Heaven I feel
like in a metaphorical sense it could be
like places that we visit in our minds
in our life
you know I don't think about it like if
you die you're going to be sent to Hell
Fire and suffer for eternity for some
people like even if like imagine if your
life on Earth is the only reality that
you have
for some people they could certainly
Define their life as hell
yeah
if you heard their life story and how it
started and How It Ends and what it was
like throughout the whole point like
that sounds like hell to me
and so sometimes I like thinking of um
you know past stories be passed through
the Bible or certain Concepts
and I know people love to take them as
literal places or literal meanings but I
think if you think about them more
abstractly in terms of The Human
Condition I think they're fascinating
because they can really apply it's kind
of like um Greek mythology
if you take it literally obviously
nobody nobody is a Hydra there's a
hydrants didn't exist there was no
[ __ ] monster that came out with all
these heads but if you think about it
sometimes you do confront problems in
life where you know
you cut one issue down and then another
one pops up and it's just like this
issue seems never ending every time I
feel it
like a Hydra could be a manifestation of
those kind of problems you know what I'm
saying or even the story of Icarus the
boy like
all of those stories were written in a
way that there was like a very strong
moral in terms of like archetypes the
person who's too ambitious for their own
good and flew too close to the sun we
can think of people that we know in that
sense
and so sometimes I I take a fascination
with a religion in that so that's like
the lessons that it passes down I think
stories do a great job of that or
concepts do a great job of like
metaphorically illustrating aspects of
The Human Condition
um so I think that's the stuff that I
think about more than anything but as
far as like the existence of gods itself
it's like you know I don't think I'll
ever get an answer so I don't know for
me it's just
is there to be to me this is what I
think about it
whether it's true or not has literally
zero meaning on my life so I don't think
about it
you know what I'm saying unless it's why
I could confirm
Jesus of Nazareth was a white man blonde
hair blue eyes lived here now he's up
there whatever
okay and he hates you for fornicating
okay yes
tell me I'm like I try to do right by
people you gave me the ability to do all
this stuff if I'm not supposed to do it
well I guess I'm going to hell Elizabeth
I accept it you know what I mean like
I'm not gonna start acting funny I start
acting crazy because now I confirmed it
like I don't
I'm not gonna start acting all different
you know what I mean because that sounds
fake now I'm just like I'm not doing
this thing that I would do just because
I don't want to no you would do this
[ __ ] out of fear that would be the only
thing that would motivate you God is the
ultimate coyote
I hate to some people that's definitely
true yeah absolutely
call me he's a God-fearing man that's a
compliment you know yeah and I'm like
okay you're afraid
yeah no I I never I never sit on
religion for that simple reason for
simple reasons like um
well I think we've had this conversation
but I'm saying
now if you have a hard life sometimes
that's the only thing keeping people
going
I would never go out and [ __ ] on
keep it whatever you need then I mean
that's for you because it helps people
through some really difficult times and
like
this whole country is like that
we just was talking earlier about how
like life is
[ __ ] frightening and scary like
realizing you're alive how do you cope
how do you cope well listen I can assure
there's a lot of people who decide not
to cope and they exit yeah
absolutely I promise you I would bet my
entire life savings that self-deletion
rates are much higher amongst atheists
than there is with religious people
yeah I would thank you
because they don't have anything to live
for
when you start to like realize like when
you believe that there's nothing out
there
and you got nothing to hold on to
and life is just like you live and you
die that's a hard thing to stop yeah and
to exist and to accept
so for so how do you make sense of that
[ __ ]
yeah say what you want about folks who
are losers but they've found something
that gives them purpose and meaning and
a way to make sense of the world so I
respect that and uh
yeah because I don't have the answers
I certainly don't have the answers so
so yeah